christophe prat idée secrétaire général
fo cheminots monsieur pratte bonjour
merci d'être en direct avec nous alors
edouard philippe jean castex j'ai envie
de vous demander est-ce que vous gagné
au change
on n'est pas gagnant ni sur l'inde et
sur l'autre on voit que de toute façon
la continuité des politiques qui veulent
mener sur les mêmes c'est tout de même
important j'imagine la personnalité du
négociateur qu'on a en face et jean iv
et jean castex est en tout cas
réputé pour ses talents de négociateur
c'est toujours important de savoir à qui
on a affaire par contre on va dire qu'à
cette première prise de parole on voit
pas de virage effectué dans dans la
ligne politique qui va être mené par ce
nouveau gouvernement
est-ce que vous avez déjà des retombées
sur ce qui s'est dit ce matin non pas en
tout cas pas directement sur notre
secteur ce qui se profile c'est de toute
façon toutes les crises qu'on traverse
et notamment la crise sanitaire enfin
l'après crise sanitaire
ces prétextes à continuer les politiques
qui sont menées en termes de réductions
d'effectifs que ce soit dans le secteur
privé ou dans le secteur public donc
pour nous c'est pas du tout rassurant
alors manifestement jean castex envie en
tout cas de remettre sur la table dans
la réforme des retraites est ce que
selon vous ça devrait être une priorité
actuellement oui la priorité de sur ce
sujet c'est c'est d'abandonner une fois
pour toutes ce projet de réforme des
retraites
aujourd'hui ce qui devrait être la
priorité d'un gouvernement dans la
situation actuelle de notre pays ce
serait de préserver les emplois de
maintenir les emplois de ceux qui ont la
chance dans l'avoir et de et de faire
tout pour faire accéder à l'emploi à
ceux qui n'en ont pas encore ou qui
aspirent à en avoir et c'est tout
l'inversé du projet de réforme des
retraites qui nous est proposé donc nous
ne pouvons pour notre pas en tout cas là
la position est inchangée cette réforme
elle est nulle non avenue et surtout pas
à propos dans la période
alors en ce qu'ils vont concernant lors
de son audition à l'assemblée nationale
jean castex a affirmé que le ferroviaire
était une priorité est ce que ça vous
rassure un peu
pas du tout ça ça confirme ce les
discours qu'ils sont tenus depuis des
années par part bien sûr la classe
politique au pouvoir mais aussi les
dirigeants d'entreprises qui qui
continue
finalement la casse du service public
ferroviaire
on peut prendre l'exemple du fret
ferroviaire où depuis des années nous
alertons sur la baisse de charge la
captation des charges par le secteur
privé
le report de tout ce qui pouvait se
faire par le rail sur la route
aujourd'hui on voit bien que au centre
des préoccupations ceni l'écologie ni
l'augmentation du ferroviaire c'est bien
au contraire
la diminution des effectifs et
l'incapacité aujourd'hui de rebondir sur
une offre et s'est bien illustrée par le
fret ferroviaire qui est aujourd'hui
dans le collimateur pour liquider ce qui
reste du peu de trafic qui nous restent
sur le territoire alors beaucoup de
plans sociaux en ce moment à airbus et
air france
nokia en tout cas beaucoup d'emplois
fragilisé sur le territoire fragilise et
même supprimé est ce qu'on doit se
préparer une rentrée à très difficile
socialement bah oui je vois franchement
pas comment il pourrait en être
autrement
on sort d'une crise sans précédent au
niveau social on va dire fin d'année et
début fin d'année 2010 9 et début 2000
20 bien sûr le sujet des retraites mais
aussi une crispation une tension
palpable dans tous les secteurs
d'activité et aujourd'hui ce qui est mis
en lumière c'est l'incapacité de
rassurer les concitoyens
ceux qui ont du travail sont sont très
inquiets et ceux qui ne l'ont pas ne
sont toujours pas rassurés
donc forcément dire aujourd'hui qu'on va
remettre sur la table des sujets comme
la réforme des retraites l'annoncent
comme vous l'avez dit de de dizaines et
de dizaines d'entreprises et on n'est
qu'au début on sait qu'on est qu'au
début aujourd'hui des bilans de l'après
crise sanitaire avec toutes les
conséquences qu'on peut imaginer
enfin écoutez on sait qu'il ya eu
énormément de subventions qui ont été
accordés à des entreprises plus ou moins
plus ou moins grosses d'ailleurs mai
mais à un moment il faut rendre des
comptes
où est cet argent comment il a été
utilisé et l'état doit prendre toutes
ses responsabilités pour préserver les
emplois
aujourd'hui on doit interdire les
licenciements on doit préserver les
emplois existants on doit protéger les
salariés
c'est ça l'urgence merci d'avoir été en
direct sur rt france rappelle que vous
êtes secrétaire général fo cheminots
merci